President Trump is also threatening
neighboring Iraq with economic sanctions
after its Parliament voted yesterday to
demand all US troops be removed from the
country Holly Williams is in Baghdad for
us Holly good morning so is this really
going to happen good morning well the
Iraqi Parliament's resolution to order
US troops out of Iraq is unlikely to
have any immediate effects but it is
devastating in its symbolism there are
roughly 5,000 US troops here in Iraq
they are here to fight Isis to protect
Iraq and the world against terrorism we
have filmed their operations and
interview them on multiple occasions
over the last five years now though
following the American assassination of
Qasem Soleimani some Iraqis are so angry
they want the US military out for good
if the military is not going to leave
what specific danger could troops be in
well this is already a very dangerous
place
Isis is still here let's not forget that
now though the US military is on high
alert and it has paused its operations
against Isis that shows the severity of
this new threat last night here in
Baghdad there were three rocket attacks
according to the Iraqi government we've
seen unverified video that apparently
shows those attacks two of the Rockets
were further related quite close to the
US embassy here in Baghdad also an Iraqi
militia group that is backed by Iran has
warned Iraqi government security forces
to stay away from US military bases here
in Iraq for their own safety and that is
a key fear that Iran will use its
proxies here in Iraq or in neighboring
Syria or elsewhere to seek revenge
against American servicemembers Tony a
lot of people holding their breath today
Holly Williams in Baghdad for us Holly
thank you very much
you